ok donc aujourd'hui ses fatigues idéal
pour brunstatt 1 n'est pas un mauricien
vous parlez des femmes de l'ombre le rap
quand dira pouvoir de fès parle de
claire on parle pas de celles qui sont
dans l'ombre qui charbonneau trois sont
toujours là c'est ce qu'on ne voit pas
avec brut on a rencontré trois femmes au
top ch irangate leila si pauline duarte
raja on commence par leïla si elle est
réalisatrice elle a bossé avec pas mal
de monde jan sobol youssoupha orelsan
valdes et bien d'autres et en ce moment
elle est en train de tout casser sur
netflix avec le film dans les arts
qu'elle a coréalisé avec kery james
on la retrouve sur le tournage de son
dernier clip il va falloir quand je vous
dis plus fort que je vous entendent par
dessus le playback master pas si j'étais
lui sans thème particulier les larmes de
kif
je suis là et l'acier je suis
réalisatrice directrice artistique
moi ça claque sa mère j'ai commencé la
danse à 11 ans et c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai découvert le hip hop la musique
leçon le rap et tout ce qui va avec
merci infiniment non mais bon passons
bien on va shooter vous êtes bien
est ce que vous voulez que je calme un
peu non mais je n'ai pas tout et on va
se calmer un petit peu s'il vous plaît
j'ai besoin de silence
vous êtes en maintenant vos personnages
là on parle pas de faire du macramé un
l'on parle de tuer un homme
alors il va lentement position la
culture hip hop a été un espèce de
twitter autour duquel j'ai réussi à
grandir mais pas de manière rigide de
manière très libre et très souple
là c'est le corps vous exagérez on
pousse pas à quelle position tu bouges
plus et musique
[Musique]
les femmes de l'ombre ce sont des
questions qui arrive depuis 2 3 ans en
fait à l'époque je regardais pas si je
travaille avec une femme ou un mec en
fait je travaille avec des individus je
travaillais avec des créatifs travaille
avec des artistes amateurs
[Musique]
maintenant je suis beaucoup plus
attentive là depuis ces dernières années
où on demande justement de donner mon
avis sur la question
coupez merci beaucoup bravo là on
commençait à voir quelque chose de bien
attention il ya monsieur kery james
vient d'arriver donc plus de bêtises
ça faisait peur
et à la fin quand tu as fini tout ça n'a
maintenant on peut peut-être essayé nous
enlève aussi ou non ces mutations que
connaît en ce qui concerne mon métier
j'ai plus aucun doute jeu quand je suis
sur un tournage je suis à ma place
par contre en ce qui me concerne moi mon
rapport à moi-même à ma vie de femme
c'est encore d'autres problématiques et
oui là je suis loin d'être une femme
forte si tu me voyait au fond mon lit en
train de chialer pour dérider nous tue
j'ai envie de te dire que non je suis
pas une femme forte et toi humaine quand
il la donne tu peux faire genre tu te la
joues un peu tu étais les gens tu aimes
ou tu détestes l'important dans la vie
c'est de ne pas laisser indifférent que
les gens aiment ou détestent tu as
rempli sa mission
on se donne encore aujourd'hui qu'on
fait des clips ou même pour le film les
gens qui nous descendent ces clichés
c'est si c'est ça je dirais quoi qu'il
arrive tu la mater et à des trucs à dire
et tu réfléchis autour du sujet donc
notre objectif est dans l'absolu remplie
la page
[Musique]
ok étaient coupées allez les gars est
dans la concentration c'est bon parce
que ça c'est pas bon allez on y retourne
la première rencontre etc mais là
c'était je pense en 2008
si tu veux
le fait de travailler avec une femme
aujourd'hui tels que les lacie fait que
je me pose plus trop la question à ce
que c'est une femme ou pas quoi on a des
rapports très très privilégiée donc
c'est quoi qui fait vite ça commence à
la net est toutefois un homme par
exemple essaie de prendre sa place
aujourd'hui ce serait très très très
compliqué pour lui quoi
ok allez aux premières positions moi je
le sentiment qu'il ya toujours eu des
femmes dans le rappeler dans le milieu
hip hop déjà les femmes sont des grandes
consommatrices de rap aussi et elles ont
toujours participé à l'histoire quoi
ce que j'aime bien c'est le combat le
combat donne une énergie qui est qui
permet de transcender en fait on vit
dans une société où c'est compliqué pour
les femmes en fait c'est misogyne mais
en vrai j'ai d'autres choses à partager
là tout de suite que dire oui c'est vrai
que dans mon milieu c'est comme si c'est
comme ça c'est comme si c'est comme ça
je vais pas me tirer une balle dans le
pied en fait oui c'est comme si mais en
fait ouvrez les yeux en fait regarder
dans quel monde on vit pour nous les
femmes comme on s'est compliqué c'est un
milieu où c'est dur mais en fait c'est
dur partout pour les nénettes et vous le
savez on s'est même si pour moi on en
train de renverser la vapeur et de
trouver dans notre féminité dans notre
regard en fait quelque chose d'hyper
puissant je pense qu'en fait si le top
peut-être une fin désolé messieurs mais
là on rentre dans l'ère de la femme et
on est au top de notre game c'est comme
ça et puis c'est tout est une question
de mentalité le regard
en parlant de meuf au top dalle raguet
on a eu la chance de rencontrer paul
duarte qui casse tout depuis des années
dans l'île du rhin français est
aujourd'hui plus dirige de la belle fait
jack girl power
c'est à la baisse historique qui a su
traverser le temps iam kool shen disiz
la peste est aujourd'hui sont toujours
là avec kobal à des carifta lâche
criminel et bien d'autres tout de suite
on la retrouve avec un de ses articles
et les 120 d'écouter son nouvel os et
des dents la râpe toute ma vie je suis
un bébé dû rapidement très chose ça me
dérange pas d'investir sur des clips
d'investir sur l'image ou sur des
contenus bien entendu mais je veux tout
soit quoi je veux pas qu'on continue de
faire des trucs qu'ils soient pas
cohérent je veux qu'on soit premier rang
et ça c'est toi qui mène la danse c'est
tout qui va faire la musique
aujourd'hui je suis peut-être d'en voir
à plus moderne avec des artistes ont
tous été très content de ma nomination
parce qu'avoir la vie d'une femme dans
la musique c'est autre chose
manager de soprano pris tout ce que je
sais c'est tout le monde m'a tout pris
des vrais artistes qui en un peu et ceux
qui réussissent sont vraiment ceux qui
donnent tout leur coeur ça me plaît pas
ça va le bureau se remplit les disques
d'or ce les murs se remplissent des
disques d'or à tenir admire j'en ai
plein par terre et vous le peuple et les
accrocher l'europe cette lenteur times
qui se passe dans les textes de rap
c'est pas la réalité vient moi mais
rappeur ils sont très crus ils seront
très hardcore et c'est des gros nounours
alors pauline suite parlé des bâtis des
nouveaux artistes que je développe dans
la boîte
pour moi le rap c'est travailler
d'arrache-pied pour un premier geste et
rainbow enfin bosseur puisque pour
l'instant il adjoint à elle à son
tableau traditionnel tu commandes et ça
je trouve que c'est bien il va pas
lâcher son taf en se disant je rappelle
tout de suite non
on est les premières moi je suis la
première femme qui dirige un label de
rap en france j'ai vécu des injustices
en tant que femme dans cette industrie
mêmes compétences tu vois des mecs
passer devant toi on leur donne des
labels toi tu bouges pas tu stagne donc
été obligé de faire du mouvement à
chaque fois que j'ai vu que ça bougeait
pas j'ai décidé de partir est-ce que je
reste là je suis bien on bat ok j'ai mon
petit salaire à touvois mais en fait je
veux plus
en fait j'ai envie de tout déchirer
c'est ça donc pourquoi lui peut le faire
- chez qu'il est moins bien et qu'il est
moins bon que moi c'était plus en
abordant moi je le sais toi tu le sais
pas je vais te le montrer
là on va montrer quechua mais entre les
femmes c'est qu'un bon on se connaît
tout c'est pas moi j'ai jamais entendu
une femme par les mâles d'une autre
femme dans le game jamais produire déjà
dit qu'une femme est promu c'est
important pour toutes les femmes
il faut oser il faut demander il faut
arrêter d'avoir peur il faut avoir
confiance en soi c'est que c'est facile
à dire mais en tout cas faut éduquer nos
filles avec des femmes fortes être comme
les garçons c'est la même chose ça passe
quand l'éducation
aujourd'hui les hommes ils ont changé
aussi sont toutes et tous les hommes des
années 80 que la société change il ya
des années les femmes dans le rap
voilà c'était beaucoup de grosses fesses
dans des clips et dans l'inconscient des
gens c'est principalement ça jusqu'à
aujourd'hui encore il faut changer des
choses
donc c'est pour ça que c'est important
de montrer des femmes du rap au site
donc ce n'est pas seulement des grosses
pièces de l'équipe ya d'autres choses
dont vous avez bien compris pas
seulement des grosses caisses de l'écrit
bouzidi a pas du tout dans le rap ya pas
du tout est requis la dernière de ce
trio de choc c'est raja impasse de vos
goûts ni à sciences po des sciences pnas
wati b et aujourd'hui elle cartonne
depuis maintenant 10 ans quand on enrage
un héros tibet qui va vous
mais quand on active et il ya sexion
d'assaut quatre que ce black m plein
d'icône du rap français qui débarque
dans les oreilles quitter pour d'autres
ravageurs tous les projets musicaux du
label wati b autant vous dire qu'elle
est à 200 à l'heure elle s'arrête jamais
une vraie pile à l'eau
ok j'y arrive j'arrive apporte 30 halle
aux espaces vip
je viendrai vous chercher je pose ça
vous allez chercher une personne au sol
alors ils sont avec moi ils ont des
bracelets l'europe je les ai découverts
en tant qu'auditrice j'ai absolument pas
baigné dans cet univers enfant merci les
gars ça va tout se passe bien
super quasiment plus de batterie ça va
commencer à devenir un des problèmes
dans les mails sont mes crissement
bonjour monsieur eto'o je reprends pas
en général
et puis quand on va au téléphone on dit
ah mais vous êtes une femme
et oui c'est absurde que c'est après
demain
aux femmes féministes pour moi c'est une
femme qui est déterminé qui essaye de se
battre contre les barrières de
l'autocensure
il ya combien de personnes soit mille
personnes ont dit l'union fait la force
anja faux agnac et on line et l'afld et
elles n'ont semblent ils pas rageant
j'ai vu elle était petite comme ça elle
était à l'école
elle est venue à la voiture gucci quand
j'ai commencé je les ai vus j'ai senti
toujours j'ai senti qu'elle avait un
potentiel énorme
c'est un milieu difficile il faut
s'accrocher des fois tu vois lâché des
larmes parce que des voitures faire des
trucs où on va dire des mots que vous
êtes un peu difficile mais raja pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est du béton pour moi n'y
a même pas de différence ex de 523 parce
qu'en vérité tout ce que je lui demande
a pu faire non plus à la le caractère
que la féliciter et j'espère qu'il va
rester nombreux fondateur doit tibériade
à voilà il ya sexion d'assaut et a vu
neuf tu as vu un truc surtout dans les
métiers ou de métiers d'art m'habitue
des métiers volant mais c'est viril ses
tables sites sûrs c'est toi eh ben elle
donc deux fois plus travailler en fait
très laid que mais mon film et du bédo
regarder vers 14h15 heure carte verte a
fait rager oublier pour peu c'est bien
s'il ya des temps pour montrer aux gens
que raie au milieu aussi voilà ce point
mais le aussi misogyne psa c'est pas en
milieu au site adapté pour mais lui
aussi dur que ça
les plus jeunes on n'a pas forcément
confiance en soi donc on prend sur soi
on je pense qu'on encaisse en réalité on
va essayer de te faire sentir que que
parfois tu es pas à ta place mais
c'était beaucoup plus quand j'étais plus
jeune
toutes les semaines c'est un réveil qui
met à l'honneur un label désormais
mythique le label du wati b avec son
boîtier bosses messieurs et voilà
comment ça va te voilà on voit bien oui
parce que j'avais l'année du mali samedi
soir
beaucoup d'artistes combien
une cinquantaine d'artistes et d'autres
invités qui viennent d'arriver aussi le
bats était là et wii puis on grandit
plus haut si on met expert dans son
domaine
plus on a confiance et plus on sait ce
qu'on dit mais il a aujourd'hui un peu
plus mais on peut vous renvoyer à la
place de femmes entre guillemets là soit
tu parles de mes compétences soit tu
parles de rien d'autre
tu parles pas d'âge ni texte pour le
coup alors la bonne nouvelle du jour
c'est que dans le rap français a de la
place pour les femmes toutes les filles
tombées tôt lundi d'un rap ce qu'il
dépose sa candidature mais tous les cv
et vous qu en deçà all-in joe hart qui
la cie raja bref les gars ya de la place
pour les femmes et de la place pour les
hommes
donc si tu kiffes le rap tente ta chance
[Musique]